[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلن تحالف القوه العراقيه الذي
يمثل التكتلات السنيه رفضه مشاركه ميليشيا
الحشد الشعبي الشيعيه في معركه الموصل
المرتقبه وقال في بيان ردا على تصريحات
لرئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي ان مشاركه
الحشد تعطي المعركه طابعا طائفيا نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هي الاسباب وراء تاكيد العبادي
مشاركه الحشد الشعبي في معركه الموصل
ومصارعه القوى السنيه
للرفض وكيف يمكن فهم مواقف بغداد في ظل
الضغوط والتدخلات الخارجيه وتمايز ولاءات
القوى السياسيه
العراقيه معركه الموصل حديث قبل اوان
انطلاقها فرضته تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
العراقي عن اشراك ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي
الشيعي فيها هذا ما يبدو للوهله الاولى
لكن نظره اخرى تكشف عن ان المعركه ربما
تكون قد بدات بالفعل وهذه ارهاصات فمسح
القوى السنيه لرفض مشاركه الحشد تعطي من
الدلالات الكثير وتط من التساؤلات ما هو
اكثر تقرير زياد
بركات ليست كل طرق تؤدي الى
الموصل هناك سيطر تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
قبل نحو عامين وتجذر ما جعل الطرق الى
معقله المكين اكثر وعوره مما يظن وممن سلك
بعض هذه الطرق هؤلاء بضع مئات من الجنود
العراقيين وصلوا الى قاعده مخمور التي
تبعد نحو 70 كيلومترا عن الموصل على امل
ان يتجمع فيها
4500 جندي قبل ان يصدر القرار بالزحف على
معقل ابي بكر
البغدادي ليست المشكله هنا بل فيما نسب
الى العباد رئيس الوزراء فالرجل يريد وقيل
لا يمانع على الاقل مشاركه قوات الحشد
الشعبي في معركه الموصل وهؤلاء كما يعرف
مليشيات ذات هويه طائفيه لجا اليها
العبادي سابقا فاصبحت فعليا اليد الضاربه
لمكون معين وتنسب اليها اكثر الجرائم
الطائفيه وحشيه في السنوات القليله
الماضيه فقد قتلت وشردت بل وقطعت جثث بعض
من تعتبرهم اعدائها وكان هؤلاء من مكون
اخر وخاصه في المناطق ذات الاغلبيه السنيه
بحيث اصبحت خارج السيطره احيانا وتنفذ
اجندات اقل من ان تكون وطنيه رغم ادعائها
غير
ذلك تلك اسباب تكفي ليعلن تحالف القوى
العراقيه السنيه رفضه المطلق لمشاركه قوات
الحشد في معركه الموصل فمشاركتك طابعا
طائفيا على المعركه كما انها تمنح تنظيم
الدوله اسبابا اضافيه لتوسيع ما تعتبر
حاضنته الشعبيه ومشروع
مضافه لاجيته المتصلبه فلماذا يتبرع
العبادي بمنح التنظيم سلاحا للنصر لم يسعى
اليه ذاك ما تثيره القوى السنيه وتطالب
بدلا منه بفتح الباب لابناء المنطقه
للتطوع والاهم تزويدهم بالسلاح امر يرفضه
العبادي فالرجل منذ وصوله الى الحكم وهو
يقاوم فكره تسليح المكون السني في محاربته
لتنظيم الدوله وسبق له ان ضرب عرض الحائط
بنصائح امريكيه وضغوط اقليميه في هذا
الصدد ويظن انه بذلك ينسجم مع تيار عريض
في المنطقه يرى في تسليح السنه تهديدا
حقيقيا لمشروع يتجاوز العراق نفسه ويمتد
الى سوريا ولبنان وسواهما كما يعتقد ان
العبادي يفاوض على الارض بقوات الحشد
الشعبي من جهه لنزع الذرائع من خصومه
السياسيين داخل المكون الشيعي الذين ير
انه اقل جذريه من سلفه المالكي ومن جهه
اخرى لاشاعه الذعر في صفوف مؤيدي تنظيم
الدوله عبر الايحاء بان ثمه تطرفا لا يقل
توحشا لدى المكون الشيعي يستطيع التصدي
لتطرف التنظيم وان البديل هو العباد نفسه
مطوع لهذا الغلو وقادرا على اعاده العراق
الى السياسه اذا بدات معركه الموصل وانتهت
لصالحه وذلك حل شك كبير كما يؤكد
خصومه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين من
بغداد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي جاسم
الموسوي ومن عمان الدكتور يحيى الكبيسي
مستشار المركز العراقي للدراسات
الاستراتيجي وابدا بضيفي من بغداد سيد
جاسم الموسوي ما الذي دفع رئيس الوزراء
السيد العبادي الى اتخاذ هذه الخطوه
بمشاركه الحشد الشعبي في معركه الموصل وهو
يعرف المواقف
من خطوه وا مووقف
كهذا شكرا جزيلا اولا دعني اقول للاسف
الشديد هذا التقرير الذي فيه مغالطات
كثيره وكبيره ولا يمس الواقع العراقي بشيء
هو تسويق طائفي بامتياز اولا القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه هو الرجل المخول الوحيد
باختيار نوع القوات التي تشارك في تحرير
جزء من العراق وليس جزءا سنيا اذا ما
حسبناه جزءا عراقيا فيحق للقائد العام
للقوات المسلحه ان يقرر هل يشارك الحشد
الشعبي او لا يشارك الحشد الشعبي ومشاركه
الحشد الشعبي سبقت في جرف النصر وفي دياله
وفي صلاح الدين وحققت انجازات ونجاحات
كبيره وتحت مظله القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه لا عرفا ولا قانونا ولا دستورا
ولا في نواميس الطبيعه ان يحدد شخصا بصفته
الشخصيه او الطائفيه او الحزبيه من يقاتل
في تحرير عدو مشترك لكل العراقيين اذا كان
داعش هو عدو السنه فقط فاعتقد هذا تسويق
خطير وتسويق غير صحيح هو عدو لكل
العراقيين والمعركه التي يخوضها العراق ضد
عدو واحد كيف يقبلون هؤلاء الذين يعترضون
على العبادي يقبلون لدوله غازيه رسميه
للاراضي العراقيه ان تشارك بالمصليه تركيا
ولا يسمحون للحشد العراقي الذي فيه سنه
وشيعه ان يشارك في تحرير مصل انا اعتقد
هنا هو التقسيم العمودي للحاله العراقيه
التي يفترض وال التي لا تتحمل ا انت ترى
سيد جاسم بان ما اقدم عليه السيد العبادي
يدخل ضمن اختصاصاته كقائد عام للقوات
الصلاح وصلاحياته وهذا ما اطرحه على ضيفي
من عمان الدكتور يحيى الكبيسي برايك لما
الاعتراض لما الاستغراب من من قرار السيد
العبادي وهو يقرر في نطاق صلاحياته كما
يقول ضيفي من
بغداد يعني بدايه مساء الخير الك جور قناه
الجزيره يعني يعني بدايه الحقيقه اعتراض
تحالف القوى السنيه او تحالف القوى
الوطنيه لا معنى له يعني هذا التحالف هو
الذي شرعن وجود الميليشيات عندما مر مرر
وزراءه الموجودين في الكابينه الوزاريه
القرار الخاص بتشكيل الميليشيات ومرر نواب
الموجودين في مجلس النواب الماده 42 من
قانون الموازنه للعام الماضي التي شرعن
وجود المليشيات التي لا شرعيه لها عذرا
المقاطعه سنناقش هذه المساله ولكن لنبدا
خطوه بخطوه لنبدا بقرار السيد العبادي في
حد ذاته ودوافع هذه الخطوه بين هي جزء من
صلاحيتي كما يقول ضيفي من بغداد وقراءه
اخرى لدوافع هذه الخطوه من قبل السيد
العبادي انت ما قراءتك
لها لا لا لا قرار الموصل ليس بيد العبادي
وليس بيد العراق يعني قرار الموصل قرار
دولي قرار امريكي قرار تركي قرار دولي
وبالتالي لا يملك السيد العبادي ان يقرر
من يشارك ومن لا يشارك من الواضح انه
المجتمع الدولي قرر تحجيم الميليشيات يعني
تحجيم هذه الميليشيات التي ارتكبت فضائع
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه ترقى الى ان تكون
جرائم حرب في كل المناطق التي دخلتها
وبالتالي السيد العبادي من خلال الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قبل ايام بدا هو ايضا
بالاستماع الى هذا الصوت الدولي من خلال
تحجيم هذه الميليشيات بفرض قائد عسكري على
في يعني في اطار اعاده هيكله هذهه
الميليشيات نحن نعرف انه انه هذه
الميليشيات تشكلت من قاده معروفين بولائهم
لايران بعملهم في ميليشيات كانت خارج اطار
الدوله طوال السنوات الماضيه اليوم في
محاوله السيد العبادي وضع الفريق محسن
الكعبي محاوله اولى لاعاده هيكله هذه
القوات ايضا يعني تقليل موارد هذه القوات
من خلال يعني الموازنه فرض على الجميع
يعني تحديدا قاده هذه الميليشيات نوع من
الشعور بانهم مستهدفون لهذا اراد المالكي
ان يطمئنهم بانهم سيشاركون بمعركه الموصل
بمعنى هذا القرار هو للتسويق الداخلي وكما
قلت لا يملك السيد العبادي ان يقرر من
يشارك ومن لا يشارك هذا وهذا الى ضيفي من
بغداد مره اخرى بالحديث عن من يقرر في
مسائل مهمه كهذه ما جرى في الرمادي على
سبيل المثال لم تشارك قوات الحشد الشعبي
في معركه الرمادي وقيل بان هذا قرار كان
من خارج العراق ما يدعمه بانه لم تشارك
هذه القوات الان ياتي السيد العبادي ويقول
بان قوه الحج سوف تشارك في الموصل
وبالتالي الى من يعود القرار ضيفي السيد
جاسم
الموسوي يعني اولا انا اتفق مع اخي الكتور
يحيى الذي حقيقه اشاد بالعبادي عندما قال
ينظم الحشد بمعنى انه يضع الحشد في اطار
الدوله والقانون وهذه خطووه ايجابيه تحسب
للدكتور العبادي من يقرر ليس المجتمع
الدولي المجتمع الدولي الشريف
في تحرير الموصل ولم يكن هو صاحب القرار
من يمنع الحشد الشعبي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهؤلاء الذين يعبرون عن راي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان اترك الحكم
للمشاع الجز لما منعت قوات الحشد من
المشاركه في معركه الرمادي على سبيل
المثال طبعا طبعا معركه معركه الرمادي
التي اعطى فرصه القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه للعشائر البطله في الانبار لتحرر
الانبار انا اعتقد هي خطوه الى الامام بل
خطوه ايجابيه ولا الذي يمنع ان تعطى
الفرصه للعشائر البطله كما سميتها في
الموصل ايضا وتتكرر نفس التجربه ما الذي
يمنع ولا ولا ولا ظير في ذلك ولا ظير في
ذلك اذا كانت هناك حقيقه بعض المخاوف لدى
اخواننا في محافظه الموصل من ان الحشد
مشاركته ستشكل عبءا انا ادعو الان من خلال
قناتكم القائد العام ليقول للحشد الشعبي
لا تشارك هناك رجال سيشاركون لكن يجب ان
نعرف ما هو الهدف من عدم مشاركه الحشد
لهذه الاصوات اولا هناك مخاوف لدى صناع
القرار في بغداد من ان دخول قوات تركيه
وكرديه وقوات فقط من العشائر السنيه سيمنح
فرصه للتنظيمات الارهابيه لان تتمكن من
الهروب او ان ان تتفق الخنادق او تصطدم
الخنادق مع بعضها البعض فيتحول الارهابي
الى وطني دافع عن الموصل ثانيا هناك خوف
كبير جدا من ان تتحول الموصل تحت هذه
القوات بعيد وفي طريقه التقسيم الط طائفي
بعيده عن العراق وبالتالي قد يكون هناك
اعلان كلبنه اولى لدوله سنيه في العراق مع
العلم ان السيد يحيى الكبيسي ايضا لم يعطي
شرعيه للنواب الذين يمثلون اتحاد القوى
بان يتحدثوا وكانوا جزء من الاتفاق مع
الدكتور العبادي لذلك انا اعتقد المخاوف
في الجانبين امر طبيعي اذا كانت هناك
مخاوف لنمنع حقيقه الحشد الشعبي من ان لا
يشارك وبهذا نكسب اولا نص تؤكد سيد جاسم
انت تؤكد بان هناك مخاوف وما ذكرناه في
التقرير ليس تجاوزا وليس
م طيب هنا اسال الدكتور يحيى فيما يتعلق
بخصوصيه الموصل وهذه الحسابات الدوليه
والاقليميه هذه المخاوف من مكون في داخل
العراق هل تخضع لحسابات هذا المكون ام
ايضا لمخاوف تتعلق بدوله جاره و تحديدا عن
ايران عندما نتكلم عن ضروره اشراك المكون
او الحشد الشعبي فيما يجري في الموصل
برايك
يعني لنتفق انه القضيه العراقيه قضيه
مدوله منذ عام 1991 يعني وبالتالي الجميع
حاضر في العراق ولا احد يستطيع ان يتحدث
عن حكومه ذات قرار مستقل او كيانات سياسيه
ذات قرار مستقل يعني هناك تداخل شديد في
العراق الجميع يعرف ذلك يعني وهناك خنادق
داخل العراق هذا اولا القضيه الثانيه
لنتفق اولا انه معركه الموصل مؤجله من
الناحيه العسكريه يعني ربما سيمر عام 2016
ولن تكون هناك يعني عمليات في الموصل ولكن
الاستعداد لعمليات الموصل تفرض جمله من
الشروط على الجميع اولا يعني الموقف من
الحشد او الميليشيات لا علاقه له بمعركه
الموصل فقط يعني واضح انه اليوم هناك صراع
شيعي شيعي على اكثر من مستوى وتحجيم هذه
الميليشيات التي تغولت كثيرا هو جزء من
هذا الصراع الشيعي الشيعي يعني لا يجب ان
نفهم قرارات السيد العبادي الاخيره تجاه
الحشد او تجاه هذه الميليشيات بانه قرار
له علاقه بالدوله لا هذا قرار هو جزء من
الصراع الشيعي الشيعي الصراع بين اليمين
المتطرف الذي تمثله هذه الميليشيات
والعقلانيه الشيعيه التي يمثلها العبادي
مع اطراف اخرى الامر الاخر هناك خشيه
اليوم في لدى هذا المعسكر العقلاني الشيعي
انه تغول الميليشيات وقدرتها على السيطره
على موارد الدوله سيجعلها خصم سياسي قوي
في الانتخابات القادمه
وربما يعني يستطيعون ان يسيطرون على هناك
ح
حسابات كثيره داخليه وخارجيه بعد فاصل
قصير نواصل بعده النقاش حول هذه القضيه
ونفصل في مسائل اخرى تتعلق بحسابات ابعد
الجانب الامريكي وكذلك حسابات دولي تتعلق
عندما يكون الحديث عن مدينه مركزيه ومنطقه
مركزيه مثل الموصل بعد
الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها قرار السيد العبادي باشراك
قوات الحشد الشعبي في معركه موصل المرتقبه
سيد جاسم الموسوي في حال ما اصرت قوه
التحالف الوطني او الموصوفه بانها سنيه
موقفها بعدم اشراك قوات الحشد الشعبي وبقي
السيد العبادي على موقفه ما تصور الايام
القادمه في ظل هذه الموقفين
برايك
يعني اولا اخي المعركه التي يخوضها العراق
معركه ذات قيم عندما تسوق سياسيا بهذه
الطريقه انا لا اقصد يعني قناتكم يعني
الكريمه اقصد تسوق من قبل الاطراف فانها
تفقد قيمتها اليوم الاتحاد القوى السنيه
اذا ما رفض مشاركه الحشد الشعبي انا اعتقد
هذه طامه كبرى لانه يتدخل في صلاحيات
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه هذه نقطه
النقطه الاخرى اصرار سواء اتحاد القوى
السنيه او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
عدم مشاركه الحشد في الموصل نفس هذا
الاصرار حدث في صلاح الدين وشارك الحشد
وحرر صلاح الدين اذا هي اراده عراقيه وتحت
رايه القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
العراقيه لذلك انا اتمنى ان لا يكون هناك
صدام او يكون هناك تسويق يصل الى درجه
اننا نفقد البوصله نقاتل داعش في من اجل
تحرير الموصل ونذهب لصراعات جانبيه على ان
هناك طائفيه وان الحشد الشيعي سيقتل
الاخوه في الموصل الحشد ليس شيعيا فيه
غالبيه شيعيه لكن فيه السنه وايضا عندما
يقول ضيفك انه صراع شيعي شيعي من اقصى
اليمين الى اقصى اليسار بين اقصى اليمين
واقصى اليسار انا اقول لك الدكتور العبادي
يعتبر معتدلا وهو الذي يطالب بالحشد واذا
كان الحشد يريد مكسبا
سياسيا انا اعتقد سيشارك الحشد اذا ما قرر
قاعد العام للقوات المسلحه في مشاركه
الحشد في الموصل وسوف تكون هذه الاراء او
هذه الحقيقه الوقفات التي ترفض مشاركه
الحشد وهذه المواقف سوف تكون لا قيمه لها
على ارض الواقع لاننا خولنا القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه ان يدرك ان العراق بحاجه
ماسه لتحرير اراضيه وهو يتحمل المسؤوليه
الكامله طيب دكتور يحيى فيما يتعلق
بالموقف الامريكي وهو فاعل ووازن فيما
يتعلق بالمسالك العراقيه الى الان بشكل
غير رسمي وغير معلم واشنطن الى حد ما ترفض
مشاركه الحشد الشعبي في عمليات في مناطق
توصف بانها سنيه ماذا لو وافقت واشنطن
بشكل رسمي على ان يكون الحشد الشعبي جزء
من القوات في معركه الموصل ماذا عن هذا
المعطى يعني بدايه لم يكن للولايات
المتحده موقف واضح وصريح من قضيه
الميليشيات وانما كان هناك تطور في الموقف
الامريكي لنتذكر عندما بدات المعارك في
جرف الصخر في امرلي كان الامريكيون داعمون
لهذه الميليشيات يعني كان هناك غطاء جوي
امريكي لعمل هذه الميليشيات وفي في معركه
صلاح الدين ايضا كان هناك دعم جوي لهذه
الميليشيات الى ان وصلنا الى معركه تكريت
وكان هناك قرار امريكي بانه لا يجب ان
تكون الميليشيات جزء من هذه المعارك
ونتذكر ما حصل حينها عندما انسحبت
الميليشيات واى اخره بمعنى لم يكن هناك
موقف امريكي واضح وصريح منذ البدايه تجاه
هذه الميليشيات ولكن كنا امام موقف متطور
بعد الجرائم التي ارتكبت في صلاح الدين
هذه الانتهاكات الواسعه التي وصفت في
تقرير في مجلس الامن الدولي بانها جرائم
ضد الانسانيه تلقى الى ان تكون جرائم حرب
الامريكيون وارادوا ان يجربوا نموذجا اخر
في في الرمادي وهو نم نموذج ان تكون هناك
قوات عسكريه تابعه للحكومه المركزيه قوات
تابعه للقوات المسلحه مع مشاركه محليه
بغطاء امريكي نجاح النسبي لمعركه الرمادي
ربما هي التي تغري الامريكان باستخدام هذا
السيناريو في معركه الموصل ولكن اذا ما
تغير هذا السيناريو وهذا ممكن يعني لا
يمكن التعويل على موقف امريكي الى الى اخر
الى نهايه الحد واضح انه الامريكيون الذين
بداوا بالقول انه لا بد من ان تكون هناك
مقاربه سياسيه بموازاه المقاربه الامنيه
انتهوا اليوم الى التعويل على المقاربه
الامنيه تماما ونسو المقاربه السياسيه
تماما واليوم هناك دعم سياسي واضح لحكومه
العبادي التي لم تقم باي خطوه باتجاه هذه
المقاربه السياسيه التي كان يطالب بها
الامريكيون لهذا لا يمكن التعويل على
الموقف الامريكي ايضا في قضيه تحالف القوى
الوطنيه لاذكر فقط انه العديد من اعضاء
هذا التحالف يعني تقف تحالف القوى السنيه
لبس الملابس العسكريه وكان يزايد على مديح
الميليشيات يعني كان هناك مزايده بين
اطراف هذا التحالف على مديح الميليشيات
احد القاده الكبار داخل هذا التحالف وصف
هادي العامري على سبيل المثال بالمجاهد
الكبير يعني لا اريد ان ادخل في هذا
السجال لهذا اقول لك بصراحه لا يمكن التع
على الموقف الامريكي الى نهايه القط اما
الموقف التحالف القوى فلا معنى له يعني
هؤلاء ليس لديهم اي قوه حقيقيه وهم غير
مؤثرين وهم صدى للاصوات التي تعلن لكن
معركه الموصل هناك كما قلت قرار دولي
الاتراك جزء اساسي من هذا الاكراد جزء
اساسي في هذا وبالتالي كل هذا الموقف
الدولي واذكرك اليوم بتقرير الذي صدر عن
يونامي يعني ممثل الامين العام في العراق
الذي تحدث لاول مره بشكل صريح عن مثل هذه
الجرائم وعن وجود انتهاكات واسعه النطاق
كل هذا يوحي بانه لا امكانيه لمشاركه
الميليشيات غير القانونيه وغير الدستوريه
في معركه الموصل لكن لا اذكرك فقط انه
اقرب رجل ميليشيا يبعد اكثر من 200 م عن
مدينه الموصل وفي هذه ال 200 كم هناك
العديد من المدن الكبرى والقرى والقصبات
ولهذا لهذا اقول لك انه معركه الموصل
المؤجله لكنن معركه سياسيه ا اساسيه قلت
بانها قرار دولي واشرت الى الجانب التركي
وان سؤالي موجه ليفي من بغداد جاسم
الموسوي انت ايضا اشرت الى تخوفات مما
وصفته بتحركات تركيه اليس من حق ايضا
المكون السني ايضا ان يخشى من خلال ادراج
الحشد الشعبي في معركه الموصل للحسابات
الايرانيه في
العراق يا اخي انا والله العظيم اخجل ان
ان يقال مكون سني ومكون شيعي ولكن على ارض
الواقع هذا الذي يج اولا دعني فقط ارد
دعني ارد فقط في نقطه مهمه اذا كان
العبادي لا يملك القرار واتحاد القوى
السنيه لا قيمه له وامريكا لا تستطيع ان
تتخذ القرار اذا من يتخذ القرار في تحرير
الموصل الملائكه من السماء اخي يحيى لا
ارجوك ان لا تتناقض هذه نقطه النقطه
الاخرى تركيا لها موقف غير ايجابي اجاه
العراق لانها نظرت الى العراق من زاويه
ضيقه يعني الان ليس كل الشيعه يعتقدون ان
ايران تقف موقف ايجابي لانها
لا يا اخي يا اخي دعني استكمل الفكره
استاذ عبد القادر ايضا هناك من الشيعه من
ينظرون ان ايران نظرت الى العراق من زاويه
ضيقه لكن ايران لم تكن لها مواقف
كالمواد جيش وقوات تحت رايه تركيه واعتراف
دولي ان يعني يعني كل العالم يدعو تركيا
لتنسحب ولا يوجد لديها شرعيه في وجودها
على الاراضي العراقيه وتقول لي ان يجب ان
نقبل الاتراك من يقبل الاتراك يقبل احتلال
وبتالي سف فقط سيد جاسم سيد جاسم ايضا جزء
من الواقعيه التي ذكرتها قبل قليل الحديث
عن التواجد العسكري الايراني سواء كما قيل
من خلال مستشفيين عسكريين او التواجد
الفعلي او من خلال الاذرع التي تاتم من
قبل ولي الفقيه في ايران حديث ايضا له ما
يدل عليه في العراق وبالتالي قول كلام يجب
ان يصدقه العراقيون
اولا استاذ عبد القادر لن تنتصر الاراده
العراقيه ان لم يكن هناك موقفا عراقيا
جامعا لا يوجد دليل على وجود قوات ايرانيه
ولست مدافعا عن ايران ولكن وج وجود
مستشارين بموافقه الحكومه العراقيه هذا
امر طبيعي لدينا استراليين لدينا اسبان
لدينا مغاربه لدينا من مصر لدينا من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من كل مكان
لدينا حتى من قطر وبالتالي انا اعتقد
الاتراك عندما دخلوا الاراضي العراقيه دون
يدان دون ان يطرق الباب جعل هناك هواجس
حقيقيه لدى الشعب العراقي لماذا تركيا
تقول ندافع عن السنه ولا تقول ندافع عن
العراق ولا نقبل بنفس الوقت ان تقول ايران
ندافع عن الشيعه ولا ندافع عن السنه نحن
شعب واحد ضحيه هذا الصراع من يحاول ان
يجعل الموصل صراعا ايرانيا تركيا هو يريد
ان يقتل العراقيين جميعا سواء سنه وشيعه
هذا ليس خطابا وطنيا لكن على ارض الواقع
يبدو ان كل الدول تستثمر المنخفض العراقي
والعراقيون حقيقه يندفعون وبشكل مؤسف جدا
الى ايران الى تركيا الى السعوديه
وبالتالي اصبحنا ضحيه لم يبقى معي الا 30
ثانيه دكتور يحيى الكبيسي في حال ما اسرت
الحكومه اسر سيد العبادي على اشراك قوات
الحشد الشعبي في معركه الموصل ما المتوقع
برايك اولا هذا القرار ليس بيد السيد
العبادي ليصر او لا يصر هذا اولا ثانيا
عندما نتحدث عن التواجد الايراني 90% من
الميليشيات العامله تحت مظله الحشد الشعبي
تؤمن بمبدا الولايه العامه المطلقه للفقيه
وبالتالي هي تؤمن بان انه يعني القرارات
التي تصدر عن الخامنئي هي قرارات تصدر عن
الح الامام الحجه الغائب وبالتالي لا مجال
لمخالفتها وبالتالي هي ليس ذراع ايراني هي
جزء عضوي من ايران الامر الثالث انا لم
اتحدث يعني لم اتحدث انه قرار المعركه ليس
بيد الولايات المتحده وان وانما قلت قرار
الحشد لهذا لم لم اكن متناقضا نعم قرار
الحرب يعني معركه المصل قرار امريكي ولكن
مساله اشراك الميليشيات من عدمها ليس هناك
قرار صريح امريكي بهذا الاتجاه اشكرك كنت
معنا من عمان الدكتور يحيى الكبيسي مستشار
مركز العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه كما
اشكر ضيفي من بغداد الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي جاسم
الموساوي بذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
ان